[Music]
hello everyone
you are listening to the value of apis
in innovation hopefully everyone's in
the right place
and everyone's having a great day
my name is chris hood i am with the
global customer success team
for apogee which is part of google cloud
and before we dive into today's topic on
innovation
i wanted to give everyone the
opportunity to jot down my
email address if you have questions or
if you would like to discuss apogee in
more detail
want to talk about your api program
please just
send me a message we are going to have a
little time at the
end to ask questions and for those who i
don't get to
then again here's a great way that we
can follow up and talk more
about innovation and apis and all things
that we like to talk about so while i
was thinking about today's topic
i couldn't help but think about the
opportunities in front of each of us
and i'm sure most of you who are
listening and probably one of the
reasons why you're here
is because of an opportunity that you
have
to create transform or even grow your
business
and hopefully after this you'll be
excited to go off and develop incredible
new digital journeys
and innovate new ideas for your
customers
innovation is a great topic
it is often seen as a driver for
competitiveness
or as a differentiator across your
products
processes and people
and this is even more true in an era of
intense competition
and continuous change where the
longevity of our products have been
decreasing and
automation has become essential and more
importantly
customers have higher demands
but how do we keep up how do we
innovate in a way that is adaptive
continuous and meaningful
one thing i share with customers when
discussing innovation
is this believing you know
what your customers want more than they
do
will cost you those customers
and here are some stats that demonstrate
this
today customers are more curious
customers visit new brands research
read reviews and price match multiple
times before making a purchase
in fact 49 of digital consumers
research a brand or product two to four
times before converting
customers are also more impatient than
ever before
at google we found that 51 percent of
digital consumers
don't believe companies meet their
expectations
and 53 percent of visits are abandoned
if the mobile experience takes longer
than three seconds to load
but the real eye opener is what
consumers will do after
poor experiences 92 percent of digital
consumers say
they would stop purchasing from a
company after three
or fewer poor experiences
and customers are also more demanding
today
and here's the important stat digital
consumers
are looking for companies that are
innovative 56
of digital consumers actively seek to
buy from the most
innovative companies the companies that
align with their own technical profile
or their digital persona and enterprises
that try to impress them
with personalized experiences
today 66 percent of digital consumers
say
it takes more to impress them than ever
before
and 65 percent expect
personalized experiences
if we return to my quote just a moment
ago
believing you know what your customers
want more than they do
here's the stat you must remember
76 percent of consumers expect companies
to
know their needs before asking them but
how do we accomplish this
how do we innovate at speed and scale
to meet the demands of customers
in 2019 that's today folks
apis are everywhere
mobile phones when you checked your
email
weather reports ordering an uber
even when you turned on today's webcast
you were using an api
more importantly apis are powering
innovation companies using apis as a
differentiator
and a competitive advantage are winning
take a look at something like uber eats
or post mates
we have one application that uses
restaurant and menu apis
driver and delivery apis payment apis
all in one seamless experience
from an enterprise point of view apis
are essential for
creating innovative business models and
innovative
modes of engagement with customers
apis have helped many businesses meet
customers increasing expectations
for connected experiences but they've
also helped
some enterprises pursue even bigger or
more profound
business evolutions things such as
unlocking new revenue streams and
product categories creating online
marketplaces executing platform business
models
and even many of the other things you'll
find in those
much loftier definitions of digital
transformation over the years we've seen
this evolution happen
api started as a way to improve access
rest as an alternative to soap http
verbs with much simpler architectures
we moved into an integration model
systems or software a connected to
system or software b
sending and receiving data between cloud
systems
and today many businesses are still
in this mindset
as enterprises have become more mature
they reach an
experienced view of apis mobile apps
powered by apis that deliver experiences
to their customers
like mobile check deposits for your bank
or
a loyalty rewards and payment system for
your favorite coffee orders but the
enterprises that
truly unlock the power of apis reach
this
transformational level digital
transformation
of the enterprise itself innovation
new revenue models improved partnerships
and increased
modes of engagement from a long-standing
integration technology to being a
powerful agent of transformation the
evolution of apis has been impressive
and exciting
today apis are the fundamental building
blocks
for successful businesses yes
apis and for those of you who don't know
what an api is
application programming interfaces
application programming interfaces are
helping companies create the
differentiators
for their products processes and people
apis are helping companies innovate
every day
to build new connected experiences
become more agile for customers
and open up new business markets to
collaborate with partners
and monetize their digital assets
apis are super powerful
but you know what the more i
actually think about it i personally
don't agree with this definition of apis
anymore
application programming
interface it sounds you know
way too technical and honestly it
doesn't capture the essence of
meaningful and continuous innovation
that we are talking about today
maybe it's time for us to actually
innovate the api
if we are truly looking at apis to help
drive our business forward while also
innovating across products
processes and people we should probably
start looking at apis
in a different way what if we change
things up a little bit
here's an option application
product interface being able to build
products and new digital experiences is
essential for
business today a few weeks ago i was
having this discussion on
uh linkedin with a group and the comment
was made that
ignoring application integration
scenarios means
ignoring 98 of the scenarios
where apis are used in the real world
today
well my response aligns with how today's
smart
enterprises need to think about apis
i stated no matter what the integration
is at the start of an api's life
is a value proposition that must
result in a business outcome
otherwise you wouldn't need the
integration
in the first place this is a complete
mindset shift apis are
not just about integration apis
must be treated as products no different
than
any other product you design build
or manage in your organization when you
design api
products you should ask questions like
what problems do my users face
how do i make the api product easy to
consume
do i start designing api products for an
internal audience or just jump right
into an external audience
can proxies be reused in multiple api
products how can i measure the impact of
my api products
the answers to these questions will form
your api
product strategy and the strategy must
support your business and you can manage
your apis as we were just talking about
like other products in your organization
with its own product life cycle
design your apis from an outside in
perspective
document them so application developers
can innovate faster
market your apis to attract new
opportunities
allowing others to help you innovate and
of course
analyze what works and what doesn't work
so that you can iterate on your apis
and if you want to get really crazy find
ways to
monetize your new api products
there are numerous approaches such as
revenue sharing
fee based models or even freemium
allowing api consumers to play with your
apis in a sandbox before subscribing
today in hundreds of organizations
globally
apis have become the business
a great example for monetization is with
accuweather
a global leader in weather data
accuweather
wanted an easy way to attract developers
monetize data via
flexible pricing plans and offer a
seamless experience that provides
customers the potential
to build the next big thing
within the first two months of going
live on the apigee platform
nearly 2500 experienced developers
paid for and accessed apis
to innovate new weather-based
applications
and as of today accuweather is
processing
over 30 billion api requests
per day another example of monetization
is with
swisscom the leading telecommunications
provider
in switzerland providing phone internet
and other services for millions of
customers
swisscom established an api program
using apogee
to bridge its network and resources to
outside
apps and products as a result
of their focus on productization of
their apis
swisscom generates millions
in revenue solely through their apogee
api program but
you know maybe we can look at apis
another way
how about application process
interface streamlining innovation
by using a platform like apogee with
tools
that allows your company to be more
nimble
might be a good way to look at the value
of apis
most companies are faced with this
challenge
the rate of change and updates at the
esb layer
and systems of records is very slow
taking months or longer to update
back-end systems to support customer
demands
while at the top your customers expect
those new digital experiences to be
available in days or sooner
apogee edge can balance the pace of
change between your back-end systems
and your front-end digital experiences
within one platform your business can
now quickly scale
manage analyze and secure apis
and data connections in order to focus
more on the connected digital
experiences
that are going to drive your business
growth
another way to streamline processes is
to look at a
basic ci cd workflow continuous
integration
and continuous delivery these processes
will help your organization
fluidly innovate while maintaining
internal governance
and adoption across your entire business
your apis can flow through this process
allowing your api consumers to develop
new experiences
and innovate faster while
also helping deliver new connected
experiences to market faster
which if you remember from our
statistics earlier
we'll directly help you keep up with the
expectations
of your customers and keep them happy
and don't forget that enterprises can
drastically accelerate app development
by seamlessly leveraging cloud services
to reduce development time improve
security
reach new markets and be more flexible
to the
changing consumer demands and markets
the real hidden benefit of app
modernization with api management
in the cloud is that an organization is
now strategically positioned to lift and
shift workloads or take advantage of
service offerings from cloud providers
based on regional availability
cost quality of services or the relative
superiority of one cloud versus another
in terms of delivering a specific
capability that you might need this
process interface helps to accelerate
time to market
increases the overall consumption and
standardization of your data
throughout your organization and greatly
decreases the chance for your
business to be disrupted
these are each the very definition of
open
innovation and here's a great example of
a company that has sustained the test of
time
while evolving their business using apis
pitney bowes a 100 year old company that
is best known for postage
meters discovered that leveraging apogee
they were able to reduce their time to
market for
new application development from 18
months
to four months as a result
pitney bose looks at apis as an entirely
new line of business
continuous process improvement using
apis
was their innovation a more recent
company
cars.com took the same approach to
modernizing their application
development
by enabling self-service onboarding and
reporting tools for business users
cars.com was able to speed up their
seller success
and improve the overall visibility into
api calls for
policies around rate limiting throttling
and security
their focus on process interfaces has
helped grow their api program
by over and twenty five percent
how about we look at apis one more way
application people interface
strong businesses link every decision
back to improving
their value propositions and
in my experience apis deliver the most
value
when serving as an interface between a
company
and people from digital marketplaces and
content platforms to smart homes
and wearable devices across virtually
all industries
connected experiences are redefining how
customers
interact with businesses and how
businesses
must engage with customers and here is
another stat
that speaks to your need for apis
by 2020 connected experiences
will overtake price and product
as the key brand differentiator
and 86 percent of buyers will pay
more for that experience
apis can no longer be a technology play
you must leverage apis to connect
with people api design from
an api first mindset begins with your
customers
typically businesses look at apis as a
means by which to expose the data on
their backend systems
out to their customers this is called an
inside
out perspective when enterprises focus
solely on integration
or exposing data from the inside out
they completely miss the opportunities
to innovate
new connected experiences for their
customers apogee helps you design and
deploy apis
from an outside-in perspective
this approach focuses on the customer's
view of your business
first leveraging their digital persona
for engaging with your products and
services and
enabling you to create connected
experiences
that resonate with their expectations
those experiences are built by app
developers
or consumers of your api products
built by your api team and that then
touch
your back end systems outside
in beginning with a digital persona you
can map
new experiences with an outside in
perspective
if done right this exercise helps bring
business and technology stakeholders
together
to understand what connected experiences
need to be developed
what apis need to be available to make
those experiences a reality
and if the back-end systems need to be
updated to support the new products and
services
apogee and apis can help you seamlessly
accelerate your innovation process
application people interfaces
allow enterprises to express parts of
their business
as digital experiences when someone
orders a movie ticket via a voice
assistant
that transaction is only possible
because the voice assistant can call an
api that expresses capabilities such as
showtime lookup or location search and
transaction approvals
regardless of whether a developer is
familiar with the underlying technology
businesses leverage apis to connect
people
to their technology and the product
that the customers care about becomes
those experiences because ultimately
if your customers are happy you will
grow your business
or to simplify this formula happy
customers
equals organizational value consider a
company like autodesk
their entire goal was to build apis
that were tailored to their customers
needs
through the apigee platform they were
able to boost
their customer engagement by three times
while also improving
time to deployment by 87
the company relentlessly looks at the
ever-changing demands of people
and quickly innovates new technologies
with apis
to keep up with those demands another
example is with philips
a global technology company that
developed a smart lighting platform
for their hue connected lights fully
controlled by a smartphone app
with apis philips took the approach to
let their engineers
focus on product development and
new digital experiences rather than
managing technical
integrations this customer-centric
management of their apis
now supports over 25 million lighting
requests
daily their goal was simple
interface their business with people
in each of these examples the key is to
understand
that innovation does not need to be
revolutionary
you must learn how to fail faster
then iterate so you can innovate
sooner when you return to your work
find the opportunities that allow your
organization to evolve
to quickly work on new ideas to keep up
with your changing markets
and to iterate towards innovation
apogee is a leader in full life cycle
api management
this is our fourth year in a row
that we've been named a leader and
gartner has positioned
apogee overall highest for our ability
to execute
your api vision and more than 700
enterprises are using apogee today to
build api
programs that generate new business
opportunities
and help innovate new experiences for
their customers
if you have specific questions about how
apis are being used in
an industry or just in general
as i said earlier please reach out to me
i'm happy to talk to you about it
and finally i wanted to share with you a
tool we have
called compass apogee compass is an
assessment tool that measures
your company's digital maturity across
10 dimensions after the webcast head
over to compass.apogee.com
or you can do a google search for apogee
compass we have 10 questions
10 dimensions and you can do it in about
10 minutes and when you have your score
share it with me i'd love to see where
you're at let's open it up for some
questions
i see some questions coming in looks
good
oh lots of good questions here uh let's
see
will this deck be available later yes
absolutely we are recording this
uh i believe we will have it available
in a video format and post it on youtube
we'll get the link out share it and then
you can share it with your colleagues
co-workers or anybody else okay
let's see uh i agree with your points
but every time i bring up the value of
apis to my
ceo or cio
they tell me that apis are for software
so go talk with the technology teams
how do i convince them that apis are
about more
than integrations it's a great question
um actually i would say that this is
exactly why we kind of put this
presentation together
i would start off by saying look
application
product interfaces application process
interfaces
application people interfaces whatever
one kind of resonates well with you
is probably going to resonate well with
your ceo
start by explaining that apis really are
about more than
integrations and that you want to talk
to them or or discuss with them
how they can help drive the business
forward
not just work on technology pieces
i think if you leverage some of the
things that we've talked about today
and again focus a lot on say the people
connectivity and
and being able to meet the demands of
the consumers
that will be a good starting point for
you in terms of
uh how do you kind of sell this
internally and get it
going up to your ceo level or executives
that care more about the business piece
okay let's see what else
you mentioned apis can help us get to
market faster
but our security teams always holds up
our innovation opportunities
what can we tell security in order to
prevent them from
blocking innovation yeah that's a good
question
uh if you go back into the presentation
a moment ago we were talking a little
bit you know about process
interface and believe it or not
a lot of the things that we have built
into apogee as a platform
including things like rate limiting and
oauth
and some security features a lot of the
policies are there
in a way so that you don't have to
jeopardize security
at the cost of trying to innovate more
you should be able to do both
in fact all of these companies and the
references that
i've shared with you today they all have
the same type of problems
you have a security team you have
governance regulations
your pipeline for your life cycles
all have this structure in it and you're
trying to kind of break free of that so
you can do
new and cool and exciting things you've
got to be able to leverage some of those
policies
that are already in place so that you
can standardize
on on security best practices
that again open you up to innovation
also the platform in general allows you
to do things like
mocking api responses
so now you don't really need security
because they're not actually touching
the back end
you're mocking of apis can be used just
to kind of
share with other partners share
throughout your ecosystem
and maybe you can innovate that way and
then once you have
something then you can start talking
about how do you reuse the policies that
are in place
to more secure those apis
possibly it's a good question
uh email me and you know we can
talk a little bit more about that
specifically let's see
i find the thought of monetizing apis
interesting
but you're talking about monetizing the
experiences consumers have
not really the integration pieces
right um
well what i am talking about is actually
monetizing
the api itself so let's say you've got
an api
that does a lookup to
all of your locations so for a retail
store this might not make sense right
because in retail
you want people to find you so all of
that location data is probably already
published out there
you know we can look for it on google
right
my my favorite store closest location to
me
and that's going to be there but when we
look at other data that
might be very valuable to your
organization
if we take an example of like
accuweather that is
a master at monetizing their data
they've got
weather forecasting information and they
can then
sell the actual transaction of that api
and they've packaged it in a way so that
consumers
can come in buy packages
of data that they want and then go off
and develop
new applications on behalf of
accuweather
so there's hundreds of applications out
there and all of those applications are
using
the apis that accuweather has published
and those developers are paying
for that access so when we talk about
monetizing your api
products we are actually looking at ways
that you can monetize the apis
themselves
and what that ultimately will do is open
up
new lines of business for you it's an
entirely new revenue stream that is now
coming in
that you can add to your bottom line
that's the key uh
let's see a couple more and and then
we're going to be out of time
uh connecting people to technology
really makes sense today but our
software engineers
don't see it that way uh
like in the pitney's example how do you
get
engineers to change their view of apis
another great question um
so there is a challenge i think for a
lot of organizations to
begin getting this adoption
of how do we look at apis it takes a lot
to
kind of transition from looking at apis
as
application programming interfaces right
where we we clearly know that these are
ways to
integrate systems and integrate software
and to kind of speed up
the development process of building
applications
and i think if you go to really any
engineering department they're going to
say yeah we have apis and yeah we
develop new apis and
that's great but when you begin to kind
of
focus on a different perspective of that
when you start looking from this outside
in perspective
in saying what do our customers want and
then i'm going to build an api
that delivers what they want
and i'm only going to connect that to
the back end when it makes
sense now you're starting to shift
that mindset and it is hard
it's very hard to kind of completely
change how engineers look at apis
but once again i think the the context
of this
uh entire webcast was to paint apis in a
different way so that you can take that
and you can go off and you can say look
we want to innovate and we want to
look at apis differently so that we can
achieve these really interesting and
exciting things that we know our
customers are asking for that's the key
and and maybe it starts by actually
having a meeting
where you bring together your business
teams and your technology teams
and you kind of outline what that vision
is and as you come together as a
kind of a cohesive view of apis then i
think you're going to be able to get to
where
pitney bowes is at okay
let's see we'll we'll get one more in
here uh
do you see apis being used differently
in different industries no
um yeah you know it's it's an
interesting question but the reality is
is
um i think at the end of the day i
share with people and and i share with
customers this
simple uh idea do you have customers
i think in every single situation
whether you're
b2c or even if you're b to b
those b to b situations the other
businesses are still your customers
everybody has customers and everybody is
trying to
meet the demands of those customers
so they're all using apis in a way that
allows them to accelerate
their development build new things again
reach markets faster all these things
we've been talking about today
but ultimately it's in a way that you
can meet the demands of
customers and since everybody has
customers
all of the industries are basically just
applying the
api philosophies to meet the
needs of their customers differently but
again i guess at the at the end of the
day it's really not that different
i want to develop something and i want
to
research it and i want to give it to my
customers and
i want to analyze it i i have kpis i
have internal goals i want to meet those
goals i want to grow my business
right i think it doesn't really matter
what industry you're in
you're all going to be trying to
accomplish the same thing
and you're all looking for ways to
innovate and as i've said
apis bring a lot of value to your
ability to innovate
and i think that's a great way to end
once again
thank you all for listening i appreciate
the time
and as i mentioned you've got my email
address once more i'm chris hood
i'm with apogee part of google cloud you
can reach me at chrishood
google.com feel free to email me and let
me know if there's anything i can help
you with
thank you again have a great day
you